die revolution der elektroautos kommt
viel früher als gedacht schon bald haben
sie reichweiten wie autos mit
verbrennungsmotoren das hat toyota jetzt
angekündigt und zwar achtung festhalten
für das nächste jahr
das ist wirklich eine hammer nachricht
und die hat weitreichende konsequenzen
welche und was die reichweiten explosion
möglich macht jetzt den blick zum
science fiction
die gibt's täglich faszinierend des
seins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen heute mit pauline
die mich mitten in der nacht auf twitter
angeschrieben hat und ohne die ich den
space ex start der star links satelliten
verpasst hätte ihr wisst das sind die
satelliten die man noch tage später am
nachthimmel sehen konnte paul ii das ist
wirklich eine bahnbrechende nachricht
toyota hat den durchbruch bei der
entwicklung von feststoff batterien
angekündigt das gab die us-
entwicklungschef chiquita sie jetzt
bekannt schon nächstes jahr zu den
olympischen spielen in japan sollen die
akkus serienreif sein
die unterschiede zu herkömmlichen
lithium-ionen-akkus hier gibt es kein
flüssiges elektrolyt sondern die energie
wird in einem feststoff gespeichert der
kann nicht wie ein flüssiges elektrolyt
bei einer beschädigung die batterie
kurzschließen akkus können so kaum noch
in brand geraten und diese akkus haben
noch ein wirklich heute noch kaum zu
glaubenden vorteil gegenüber lithium
ionen akkus die energiedichte ist etwa
zwei zweieinhalb mal größer sprich die
reichweite wurde ebenso wachsen
ein tesla wurde also mit einem solchen
energie pack rund 1500 kilometer weit
kommen
also rund doppelt so weit wie ein
fahrzeug mit verbrennungsmotor
und hinzu kommt das batteriemanagement
ist viel aufwendiger da feststoff akkus
nicht so leicht überhitzen können und in
einem größeren temperaturbereich optimal
arbeiten hier dürfte noch mal gewicht
wegfallen sodass in der praxis noch
größere reichweite möglich sind moment
das bedeutet schlichtweg elektro autos
überholen verbrenner im wahrsten sinne
des wortes und com rund doppelt so weit
ich denke diskussion über reichweiten
ist damit vom tisch
zudem lassen sich die feststoffe akkus
viel schneller laden
sie sind wirklich die eierlegenden
wollmilchsau für die elektromobilität
und mal wieder haben viele und da fasst
man sich an den kopf nicht irgendwelche
leute sondern expertinnen und experten
entwicklung vollkommen falsch
eingeschätzt lithium ionen akkus werden
noch für viele jahre die eigentliche
batterietechnologie sein gegenüber strom
auch begrenzten raum speichern kann und
sich oft genug wieder aufladen um autos
um die busse oder gabelstapler
anzutreiben sagt dangel küper in einem
artikel der wirtschaftswoche vom 14 2018
sein spezialgebiet batterietechnik bei
der unternehmensberatung boston
consulting group
es ist wie so oft die vermeintlichen
fachleute schätzen die entwicklung
vollkommen falsch ein
wie toyota übriges zu gibt der
autohersteller zieht die roadmap also
den zeitplan für die einführung von
elektroautos und fünf jahre vor
schon nächstes jahr soll die festkörper
batterie der breiten öffentlichkeit
vorgestellt werden
das kompaktauto soll dann auch auf den
markt kommen zunächst mit zwei plätzen
und 100 kilometern reichweite
in der folge sollen dann basierend auf
einer neuen plattform vans limousin und
große suvs gebaut werden
die lithium akku mit zehnfacher
energiedichte revolution der
batterietechnik anklicken anschauen und
klickst du abonnieren dann könnt ihr
auch mich hier ab und zu mal sehen